-D'Arcy, it's so great
to see you.
-Hey.
Holy cow, you just had a baby.
-I just had a baby.
-What do you guys think of that?
-And it is a crazy --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Crazy thing.
And we have actually known
each other for a while.
We -- well, we were
in a wedding together.
-Our friend John Mulaney
and Anna Tendler got married.
-They did.
-And we both gave toasts
at the wedding.
-Yeah, and I don't know if you
can imagine giving a toast
at, like, a stand-up comedian's
wedding.
It's full of stand-up comedians.
It's stressful, and I went
first, and I was really nervous,
and you were there, and some
people that I really look up to,
and I did my speech,
and I kind of killed.
-You did great.
-I did great.
-Great.
-And then up next was Seth,
and then you actually killed.
-I had a good toast. Yeah.
-You had a good set.
[ Laughter ]
-It was, like, really good.
I was like, "Oh, that's --
Okay. No, I get it.
That's what it should have been.
That's how you do a toast."
And then, you know, I was like
well -- I did --
We did our speeches.
It is what it is.
But then who comes out next was
John Mulaney's dad,
which I actually was like, "Oh,
he shouldn't go after Seth.
They should have had him first.
This is a dad.
He's going to do, like,
weird dad things."
He truly killed.
-Murdered.
-Made us all look like lawyers.
-The worst.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we were his like --
we opened for him.
-Yeah, it was fantastic.
-He was amazing.
-I want to talk about "Barry,"
which is a fantastic show.
Bill Hader plays a hitman
in an acting class.
-Bill Hader.
-You are in the acting class
with him.
Yes, Bill Hader right there.
There he is.
Little Bill.
-Little Bill.
-You first met Bill
because you --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there he is.
-Oh, yeah. Little Bill.
-You nannied for him
like 10 years ago.
-I did. Yes.
I was his nanny for their oldest
two daughters,
and that was
like my full-time job.
I was with them every day.
I still am really close
with them.
I -- The oldest one
in particular
I, like, hung out with
every day.
We were like best friends.
-Yeah.
-Like, that happens,
and we kind of would just talk
like friends would talk,
and she, I think, maybe took
after me too much or something.
I remember one day I was holding
my phone, and I dropped it,
and I just kind of under my
breathe was like, "Oh, damn,"
and she looked up at me,
and she's, by the way,
she's two years old,
maybe two and a half,
and she looked up and she goes,
"Oh, [bleep]. You pooped?"
[ Laughter ]
-She thought that's what you
were upset about?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, that's a good friend.
-I know.
-That's a good girlfriend.
-That's a best friend.
She really knows.
-Yeah, 'cause you want the help.
If that happens,
you want help right away.
-No judgment.
You just -- She gets it. Yeah.
-Here's my "I'm gonna wrap
my coat around your waist,
and we're gonna find somewhere."
-She would do that for me.
-She would do that for you.
You also play Janet
on "The Good Place,"
which is a fantastic role.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That you have described as Siri
if Siri had a body.
-Yes, which is exactly --
I mean, she just --
she knows everything.
She's got all the answers.
-Is it so much fun to be playing
that part
on that wonderful show?
-It is the most fun I've ever
had doing anything ever.
-That's pretty good.
-Yeah, so it's the best --
it's the best job,
and the cast is amazing.
-And you work with Ted Danson
who is, I know from experience,
is the nicest person on Earth.
-He loves you.
-He's wonderful.
He plays -- He plays a demon
on this show.
-Spoiler!
-Yeah, spoiler.
-Catch up, yeah.
-It was a first-season,
first-season spoiler.
-Yes.
-But he did not play
by spoiler rules.
-No, he didn't. We were
instructed not to tell anyone.
Like, don't tell
your husband or wife.
Don't tell your family, anyone
what this big twist was,
and we really stuck to it,
except he did not,
and we found out later
that he did not.
Ted would explain the story to
friends or whoever,
and they would be like, "Oh,
cool. Yeah, that sounds cute.
And he would be like,
"Oh, that's cute?
You think that's cute?
Let me tell you what's cute."
And then he would tell them
the big spoiler
'cause he couldn't handle not --
He wanted the reaction of like,
"Wow, this is really worth
coming back to TV for
or whatever."
[ Laughter ]
But, obviously, joke's on them?
-Yeah, joke's on them.
-I don't know.
-You also --
We did not meet then.
I was there.
You were an extra on
"Saturday Night Live" in 2005.
-Okay, yeah, that's true.
-So this is --
David Spade is hosting.
-Oh, no, yeah.
-And you were -- you were -- you
played a woman in the audience,
and Martha Stewart.
-Yes, I did.
-So there is D'Arcy right there.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. And you know what?
I'm really acting my butt off.
-Yeah, I will say that you were
doing more acting
than certainly anybody else
here.
-And can I tell you something?
At the time I knew it.
I knew I was doing a good job.
-Because I want to say
you didn't just stay
in that position.
You went that. You went
praying hands like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, can I tell you the scene
called for it?
-Yeah.
-So, that's called good acting.
-What I think it really called
for was the fist pump.
Look at you.
[ Laughter ]
Fully doing
your paid extra work.
-Why? Why did I do that? Why?
-That was great.
Did you feel like you were
amongst peers
when you were in the back
with the extras?
-You know, I -- No, I was like,
"I'm not like them."
[ Laughter ]
Extra work is
so weird and strange,
and a lot of actors have done
it, or, you know, do do it.
And it is a weird little world.
Yeah, when I was doing extra
work, I was like,
"Mnh-mnh, this is not for me.
I can't -- I can't do this."
But I did it,
and you see that I did it.
-You fully did it.
-I fully did it.
-My last question for you is
D'Arcy is spelled
D, apostrophe, arcy.
-Yes.
-And this was not your --
This was a choice you made.
-That's right.
-Your parents named you Darcy
no apostrophe.
-My parents named me
normal Darcy,
and then when I was
in junior high,
I became obsessed with the band
Smashing Pumpkins,
which many of us did.
-Sure, who wouldn't?
Of course, yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Okay, cool.
And the bass player was
this very cool chick
named D'Arcy with an apostrophe,
and when I found that out,
I truly just switched it
and never looked back.
Like I didn't --
It wasn't a big decision.
-Did your parents care?
-They did.
-They did? Okay, great.
-They didn't love it.
-Yeah.
And that's fantastic,
but it just stuck from there,
and you never looked back.
-I never looked back.
-Well, it's great.
It's a very cool way
to spell it,
and I sign off on it.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Not that you were waiting
for me to sign off.
-No, I was,
this moment actually.
-Okay, great. Thank you so much
for being here. D'Arcy Carden.